Horror cinema is booming right now, and the
scares don't seem to be slowing down at all
in 2020.
The next decade of cinema scares will kick
off in a big way, with everything from long-awaited
sequels to daring reboots to new takes on
some classic ghost stories.
In 2004, two years after The Ring launched
a wave of American interest in Japanese horror
cinema, we got The Grudge.
This English-language remake of the 2002 Japanese
scarefest Ju-On brought stateside audiences
a look at the curses and hauntings that form
in places where angry, violent deaths have
occurred.
The Grudge got two sequels in 2006 and 2009,
but the Ju-On franchise has continued in Japan
with nine films and counting.
Now, the American remake franchise is getting
its own reboot.
Grudge will serve to reset the American version
of the franchise with a new story of a vengeful
spirit haunting a house where past violence
took place and formed a curse.
The film features an impressive cast led by
Andrea Riseborough, Demian Bichir, and Jacki
Weaver.
The film was originally set to be released
in June of 2019, but was later pushed back
to January 3, 2020.
Henry James' novella The Turn of the Screw
is one of the most popular and influential
ghost stories ever written, and it's been
adapted for the screen numerous times.
In 2020, the classic tale will get a new,
modern take with The Turning.
This version of the story will be set in modern
Maine, but will still tell the story of a
governess tasked with caring for two young
children after the deaths of their parents.
As she settles in for the job, she begins
to suspect the mysterious estate where the
family is living may be harboring a number
of dark secrets, and may in fact be haunted.
The film is worth getting excited about for
any number of reasons.
It's Floria Sigismondi's second feature film
after The Runaways, and it'll be fascinating
to see how she adapts her visual style, honed
in music videos and episodes of prestige TV,
to this ghost story setting.
The cast is also stacked with talent thanks
to the presence of Mackenzie Davis, Finn Wolfhard,
and Brooklyn Prince, and the story is iconic.
The Turning will hit theaters January 24,
2020.
In 2014, Universal Pictures tried to revamp
its universe of classic movie monsters with
the prequel story Dracula Untold.
It didn't quite land, but in 2017 they tried
again with an even more ambitious effort,
an attempt to launch an interconnected "Dark
Universe" with The Mummy.
That film also didn't work out, so for now
it seems the studio is refocusing its intentions
with more standalone efforts.
The Invisible Man is the first of these, and
it will be directed by Leigh Whannell, the
man responsible for giving us Saw, Insidious
and Upgrade.
The Invisible Man is scheduled to hit the
screen on March 13, 2020.
A Quiet Place was one of the most successful
and acclaimed genre films of 2018, and it
didn't take long for talks of a sequel to
emerge after it hit big with audiences.
John Krasinski will return to both write and
direct the second installment in the franchise,
while his wife Emily Blunt will also return
to star.
The film's full plot is still unknown, but
we do know it will follow the surviving members
of the Abbott family, now led by Blunt's Evelyn,
as they continue to try to survive together
after learning a trick to defeating the creatures
at the end of the first film.
Will a third installment follow?
We'll have to wait and see.
A Quiet Place 2 sneaks into theaters March
20, 2020.
In May of 2019, the internet was both delighted
and a little confused by reports that legendary
comedian Chris Rock would be venturing into
horror territory with a new spin-off film
set in the Saw universe.
The ninth Saw film, working from a story developed
by Rock, is in development and will hit theaters
in the spring of 2020.
"Bigs and van der beek are on the set.
Well I don't see them.
Where are the stars of this piece of s---?"
We still don't know much about the film's
plot, but we do know that Rock is also set
to star as a detective investigating a killer
who likes to build elaborate puzzles for his
victims, and that Samuel L. Jackson has added
even more star power to the cast after signing
on the play the father of Rock's character.
The still-untitled ninth Saw film hits theaters
May 15, 2020.
In 1992, a new horror legend was born with
Candyman, a story about a hook-handed killer
who lived on as a vengeful, murderous urban
legend long after he was the victim of a lynch
mob in the 19th century.
Candyman is a modern horror masterpiece that
spawned two sequels and lives on through a
devoted fanbase eager to analyze every piece
of this often deceptively deep film.
"You and I, our bones will soon be ashes,
and we shall never be separated again."
Candyman's ongoing reputation as one of the
best horror films of the 1990s was enough
to draw attention from Jordan Peele, who's
now helping bring a spiritual sequel to the
original film to the big screen.
Candyman 2020 will be directed by Nia DaCosta
from a script by Peele and his Monkeypaw Productions
partner, Win Rosenfeld.
The still-mysterious Candyman arrives on the
big screen June 12, 2020.
In 2013, a relatively small scale horror film
about a pair of paranormal investigators blew
up at the box office.
That film was The Conjuring, and in just six
years, it spawned one direct sequel and five
spin-off films.
The Conjuring Universe has become a horror
juggernaut for the 2010s, and in 2020 the
third film in the main series will finally
arrive on the big screen.
Not much is known yet about the plot of The
Conjuring 3, which will feature the return
of Patrick Wilson and Vera Farmiga as the
Warrens and will be directed by Michael Chaves,
who helmed the spinoff The Curse of La Llorona.
We also know that it will veer away from the
haunted house format offered in the first
two films.
The Conjuring 3 will be terrifying audiences
on September 11, 2020.
In 2018, director David Gordon Green brought
star Jamie Lee Curtis back to the Halloween
franchise with a new film that ignored all
previous sequels, setting the stage for a
showdown between Laurie Strode and Michael
Myers that, in this universe, had been four
decades in the making.
That film, simply titled Halloween, was one
of the year's biggest horror hits, and though
it could have closed the book on the franchise,
talk of a sequel began to surface.
In July of 2019, we found out that we'd be
getting not just one, but two sequels in the
span of two years.
The first of those, Halloween Kills, will
arrive in 2020.
Green will return to direct and co-write the
film with Danny McBride, while Curtis will
also return as Laurie Strode with Judy Greer
and Andi Matichak returning as Laurie's daughter
and granddaughter, respectively.
Given how the past film set up a legacy of
strong women in the Strode family, it'll be
very intriguing to see how the next film expands
on this new version of the mythology.
Halloween Kills arrives October 16, 2020.
It will be followed by the final film in the
trilogy, Halloween Ends, on October 15, 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
scary movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.